.
* Klingelton *
* Fauchen *
Cosa?
Hallo. Guten Tag.
Ich bin Stefano.
Er heisst Stefano.
- Willst du übersetzen?
Mama!
- Komm her!
Nein!
Komm her! Jetzt kommt Ahmad!
No, non capisce. Ahmad.
Ahmad!
- Ciao!
Sie versteht dich nicht.
Ahmad kommt.
Er fragt sie jedes Mal:
"Wann kommst du? Wann kommst du?"
Nur das.
- Wie geht es dir, Mama?
Willst du auch
mit deiner Mutter sprechen?- Ja.
Ich zeige dir,
wie Papa jetzt aussieht.
* Lachen *
Kameran!
Hier bin ich. Gib mal her.
- Nein!
Er hat zu meiner Mama gesagt:
"Du bist ..." Wie heisst das?
Stefano.
- Nein, das hier, wie sagt man dem?
Herz.
Herz. Er hat zu ihr gesagt:
"Du ... Herz."
Ach so, er hat gesagt:
"Du bist in meinem Herzen."
Ich liebe dich, Mama.
Ich liebe dich auch.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Orientalisch anmutende Zupfklänge *
Lieber Ahmad, wer weiss,
ob du dich noch daran erinnerst,
wie du als kleines Kind vor dem Krieg
in Syrien geflüchtet bist.
Wie dein Vater
stundenlang marschierte
und einen Sack
auf den Schultern trug.
Das warst du, lieber Ahmad.
Mit baumelndem Kopf hast du
Hunderte von Kilometern zurückgelegt,
um in den Irak zu gelangen.
Alle gingen mit euch:
deine Mutter, deine Schwester
und deine beiden Brüder.
Eines Tages wird dir deine Mutter
bestimmt erzählen,
dass ihr damals
kein Geld mehr hattet,
um eure Flucht
gemeinsam fortzusetzen,
und dass sie dich
mit deinem Vater und deinem Bruder
alleine weiterziehen liess,
damit ihr das Land erreichen könntet,
wo man - wie sie glaubte -
dich heilen könnte: die Schweiz.
Das ist mein Name,
ich will ihn anfassen.
(Frau) Mach die Augen zu
und träum was Schönes.
Wie wir es das letzte Mal
gemacht haben. Schliess die Augen!
Was siehst du? Siehst du
die zwei hübschen blauen Fische?
Während eurer Zeit in Giubiasco
wart ihr von vielen Menschen umgeben,
die euch helfen wollten.
Was siehst du? Nemo?
Aber dann ist der Traum geplatzt
und wie im Leiterspiel
standet ihr nach knapp zwei Jahren
wieder ganz unten an der Leiter.
Das war an dem Tag, an dem ihr
die Schweiz verlassen musstet
und nach Deutschland
zurückgeschickt wurdet.
Doch du bist lange genug
in Giubiasco gewesen,
um ein bleibendes Zeichen
zu hinterlassen.
Wer sind die Freunde
von Ahmad und Falamaz?
Wir!
- Ihr seid ihre Freunde?
Ich habe Falamaz getroffen.
Jetzt lebt Ahmad
in einer kleinen Stadt.
In Deutschland.
Ich habe ihn besucht. Im Legoland.
Genau, in der Nähe vom Legoland
in Deutschland.
D.h., sie sind
in ein anderes Land gezogen.
Ziehen sie jetzt ständig
von einem Land ins andere?
Wir hoffen,
sie können in Deutschland bleiben
oder gar
in die Schweiz zurückkehren.
Stoss du mal!
(Durchsage) Nächster Halt:
Plankenweg.
* Niesen *
* Lachen *
(Durchsage) Nächster Halt ...
Du darfst die Augen
nicht schliessen,
du musst sie offenhalten.
Und nicht lachen.
Öffne die Augen, so ist es gut.
(Automatenstimme) Jetzt geht's los.
- Nicht bewegen.
Mal sehen.
(Frau) Das ist dann hier hinten,
Zimmer 25.
Fünf ... Five seven.
- Genau, es steht ...
Äh, hier, 25.
- Ah, si.
Danke. Tschüss.
- Bitte! Tschüss.
(Frau) Kindergeld läuft
über die Familienkasse.
Die ist aber in Ravensburg.
Aber die Anträge
gibt es entweder auf den Rathäusern,
oder vielleicht
bei der Agentur für Arbeit fragen.
Die Familienkasse gehört ja
zur Agentur für Arbeit.- Ja.
Das muss er dann auf jeden Fall
beantragen für sein Kind.
* Melancholische Flötenmusik *
Schaut da, am Himmel!
Warum fliegt es genau über uns?
Es bringt die Leute
zum nahen Flughafen.
Vielleicht wollte es auch
einen Hamburger.
Papa!
Letztes Jahr habe ich euch
von der Dublin-Verordnung erzählt,
die bestimmt, dass Asylsuchende
sich in dem Land aufhalten müssen,
wo sie registriert wurden, d.h., wo
ihre Fingerabdrücke genommen wurden.
Nach zwei Jahren im Tessin
ist die Familie damit einverstanden,
nach Deutschland zurückzukehren.
Weil sie hofft,
dass dadurch die Mutter
und die beiden Geschwister
nachkommen können,
wie es ihnen versprochen wurde.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Papa!
* Ahmad
spricht weinend italienisch. *
* Heulen *
* Unverständlicher Ruf *
Papa!
Wo hast du das Telefon hingetan?
* Sie sprechen arabisch. *
(Kindergärtnerin)
Er weiss, dass er heute um 14 Uhr
in seinem Zimmer sein muss,
um auf etwas ganz Bestimmtes
zu warten.
Wo steckt er bloss? Jetzt ...
Hallo, mein Kleiner! Schau mal!
(Alle) Ciao!
- Hallo, Anna!
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
* Lachen *
(Frau) Wie geht's dir, Ahmad?
Ich habe immer noch euer Foto.
Ich habe es nicht weggeschmissen!
Wir haben es
auch nicht weggeschmissen.
Es hängt neben dem Fenster.
- Ciao, ciao!
Hast du schon neue Freunde gefunden?
Ein paar.
Ah! Gehst du auch zur Schule?
Nein, nur ... nur ...
Bei uns hast du Italienisch gelernt,
erinnerst du dich?
Lernst du jetzt auch Deutsch?
Italienisch
kann ich jetzt noch besser.
Das ist ja toll.
(Frau) Schau mal, Falamaz!
* Lachen *
Das ist dein Stuhl.
Ein Schulkamerad
will dich was fragen.
Wer denn?
- Ich bin's, Jonathan.
Ach so, "Jonada"!
Und jetzt musst du herausfinden,
wer das ist.
Hey, Alfri! Wie geht's?
- Gut. Wie geht's dir?
Ich vermisse dich, Mann.
- Ich dich auch.
Ob keiner einen Zahn verloren hat,
fragt er.
Und ob.
Wir haben einige Zähne verloren!
Ich schon.
- Ich vier.
Ich habe zwei verloren.
Wir sagen dir jetzt alle zusammen
Ciao
und schicken dir einen dicken Kuss!
(Alle) Ciao!
* Sanfte Klavier- und Gitarrenmusik *
Während eurer Zeit in Giubiasco
wart ihr so oft bei uns zu Hause,
dass meine Partnerin Debora
dich und Falamaz
zum Essen jeweils gleich mitzählte.
Und ich glaube,
dass unsere kleine Tochter Ariella
immer mehr Freude daran fand,
zwei grosse Brüder zu haben.
Ariella!
Heute Morgen
hat sich Ariella Zöpfchen gemacht,
schau mal.
* Ahmad lacht kurz. *
Siehst du sie?
Ist sie ein Pferd geworden?
Wie ein Pferd.
Kommst du heute nicht zu uns?
Heute nicht, nächste Woche.
Verstanden?
In sieben Tagen.
- So viele?
Da steht er, schau!
Hallo Falamaz. Wie geht's?
Gut, und euch? Hallo Giuliana.
Ciao Ahmad!
- Ciao!
Hast du das Huhn gekocht?
Ja, ich koche jeden Tag.
Nimm es so, mit der Hand,
dann nimmst du das Glas.
Bravo!
Schmeckt gut.
- Vielen Dank!
Wenn meine Mutter erst da ist,
wird sie für euch kochen.
Sie ist die beste Köchin der Welt,
für mich zumindest.
* Klingelton *
Deine Mutter?
- Ja.
Sprich mit Falamaz, dann kann er
gleich für alle übersetzen.
Mama, wann, glaubst du,
könnt ihr kommen?
Ich hoffe von Herzen,
dass wir in weniger als einem Monat
unsere Bewilligung haben.
Hoffentlich. - Du weisst ja,
was für ein grosses Herz Mama hat.
... sieben, acht, neun, zehn -
ich komme!
Wir sind zu Hause.
- Du armer Schatz.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Warte!
Wir müssen noch die Ohren abspülen.
So, jetzt sind wir fertig.
Wo ziehen wir ihn an?
Drüben, hier ist es zu kalt.
- Ja, drüben ist es wärmer.
Sind die schon trocken?
- Ja, die sind von gestern.
Die auch?
- Ja. Es fehlt nicht mehr viel.
* Melancholische Flöten-
und Klaviermusik *
* Arabischer Gesang *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
* Seufzen *
Wie ich das hasse,
wenn man mich morgens weckt.
* Scheppern *
Nur das hier.
(Mann) Gehen wir.
Wir haben heute unseren Termin.
Endlich.
(Frau) Ahmad, kannst du dich
alleine an- und ausziehen?
* Der Dolmetscher spricht arabisch. *
Was?
Nein.
Wie? Was sagt ihr da? "Nein, nein"?
Er kann schon,
er will nur nicht helfen, oder?
* Sie sprechen arabisch. *
Papa?Was fragt dieser Esel so blöd?
Hey! Hey, hey, hey.
Und das hier? Weg damit!
- Ahmad!
Okay, komm, wir lassen ihn in Ruhe.
Die Frau schreibt, damit du
endlich zur Schule gehen kannst.
Wenn du sie ärgerst,
macht sie nichts mehr.
Willst du, dass alle
zur Schule gehen, nur du nicht?
Morgen, morgen, morgen.
- Morgen gehst du zur Schule.
Ahmad, heute musst du
früh ins Bett gehen, gell.
Er muss heute früh ins Bett.
Heute, 21 Uhr, 20 Uhr ins Bett.
* Sie sprechen arabisch,
Ahmad weint. *
Er hat es nicht leicht, ja?
Er hat es nicht leicht.
* Ahmad schreit und weint. *
Steh auf!
* Weinen *
(Durchsage)
Sankt Elisabeth, Werastrasse.
* Sphärische Musik *
Guten Abend, Dr. Ramelli,
hier spricht Debora.
Ich wollte unseren Termin
von heute Abend bestätigen.
(Lehrerin) Falamaz, ich weiss nicht,
ob du es schon weisst:
Wir kommen euch bald
wieder besuchen. Ganz bestimmt.
Das ist schön.
Aber ihr ...
Wir können dir nicht sagen,
wann genau.
Vielleicht
sind wir wieder dieselbe Gruppe,
vielleicht kommen andere.
Auf jeden Fall
wird euch jetzt immer wieder mal
jemand besuchen
und du erzählst,
wie es in der Schule läuft.
Das Traurige an der Geschichte ist,
dass sie hier
eine Lebensform gefunden hatten,
die ihnen etwas Ruhe gab.
Das war das Wichtigste für sie.
Bis jetzt ist Ahmad nicht einmal
ärztlich untersucht worden.
Das verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Bei einem Kind mit dieser Art
von Fehlbildung am Rücken
wird bei uns sofort
die ärztliche Betreuung übernommen,
damit es ein normales Leben führen
und wieder gehen kann.- Gehen?
Aber ja. Es waren diverse
Rehabilitationstherapien vorgesehen,
um Ahmad eine optimale
Lebensqualität zu ermöglichen.
Ich hatte ihn bereits untersucht
und alles eingeleitet,
als plötzlich alles gestoppt wurde
mit der Begründung,
es sei noch unklar, wo er hinkäme.
Ich war vor den Kopf gestossen,
denn je mehr Zeit vergeht,
desto schwieriger wird es
für das Kind.
* Motorengeräusche *
Da oben sind runde Sterne.
Ahmad, unter diesem schönen Mond
könnten wir ein Gebet sprechen,
damit die Mama bald kommt.
Lieber Gott, wir beten zu dir
unter diesem Vollmond:
Mach, dass die Mama
bald herkommen kann.
Lieber Gott ... Und weiter?
Wir beten zu dir
unter diesem Vollmond.
Mach, dass die Mama bald kommt.
Wir möchten sie
so gerne wiedersehen.
Sie fehlt uns sehr.
- Ganz fest. Brr, ist das kalt!
* Klingelton *
Hallo?
- Kameran?
Kameran, morgen Nachmittag
kommen wir nach Deutschland.
Domani pomeriggio,
veniamo in Germania noi.
Am Donnerstag gehen wir alle
zusammen nach Ravensburg zum Arzt,
wegen Ahmad.
Morgen koche ich gelben Risotto.
Du musst also nicht kochen.
Mama, sind wir schon da?
Hm?
- Fast.
* Ahmad singt. *
Komm auf diese Seite! Hallo.
* Ahmad lacht. *
Ariellona! Du erwischst mich nicht!
Du mit deiner Katze!
* Fröhliches Kreischen,
melancholische Klaviermusik *
Schau mal!
* Lachen *
Und ob ich dich erwische!
* Fröhliches Kreischen,
melancholische Klaviermusik *
Es riecht wunderbar.
- Noch ein bisschen?
Das habe ich schon so lange
nicht mehr gegessen.- Wunderbar.
Gelber Risotto.
Bravo!
Und für Ahmad.
Gelber Risotto.
* Ausgelassenes Lachen *
Stell dich näher an die Wand.
Ich kann nicht.
- Nein?
Lauf mal zu mir!
Ja, genau.
Ja, tipptopp. Gut.
Okay.
- Hopp!
Du musst auch deine Hose ausziehen.
Und Strümpfe ausziehen.
Hopp?
- Genau. So ist gut.
Nein, nein.
Du machst es alleine, gell?
Grosser Junge.
Jetzt fahre ich noch mal runter.
Will Papa noch was zeigen?
Er spürt nichts? Ja.
* Er spricht arabisch. *
Du bist ein guter Patient.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Das hier ist sozusagen der Hüftkopf.
- Ja, ja.
In etwa. Ach, super Stift.
Il collo del femore.
Da habe ich vielleicht 30 %,
die nicht in der Pfanne stehen.
Hier habe ich fast 100 %.
Ah.
E qui, quasi 100 % che e fuori.
Es ist relativ wahrscheinlich,
dass man das operieren muss.
Ist es hier und hier?
Nein, nur hier.
- Nur hier?
Du musst operiert werden.
Zieh dich hoch,
ich schaffe das nicht.
Und nach der Operation bekommst du
diese speziellen Stiefel,
mit denen du gehen lernen kannst.
Und wie nehmen sie den Knochen raus?
Mit einer Operation. Du musst
für zwei Wochen ins Krankenhaus.
Allein?
So wird der Knochen
wieder beweglich.
Dann machen sie wieder zu.
Sie setzen eine Art Eisen ein,
das er ein Jahr lang drin hat,
und dann wird dein Sohn
gehen können.
Ich bete zu Gott.
Was war denn los?
Ich habe gehört, du hättest geweint.
Warum denn?
Na, hör mal, wegen so
einer Kleinigkeit weinst du?
Bei einer Herzoperation
könnte ich es ja noch verstehen,
aber das hier ist Routinesache.
Was ist denn, Mama?
Willst du, dass er gehen kann,
oder nicht?
Ich will schon,
dass mein Kind operiert wird,
aber es tut mir weh,
dass ich nicht bei ihm sein kann.
Willst du, dass er gehen kann,
oder nicht?
Oder muss ich dir zuerst zeigen,
wie viele Schnitte ich
auf meinem Körper habe?
Ich mach's!
Mach mir keine Angst!
Ich vermisse euch.
Ja, ja.
Vermisst du auch mich?
- Sicher, du bist doch mein Sohn.
Ja.
Ohne euch fühle ich mich,
als hätte man mir das Herz
aus dem Leib gerissen.
Mein Goldschatz.
Ich nehme dein Herz
und verschlucke es.
So ist dein Herz
immer in meinem drin. Stimmt's?
Gib mir noch einen Kuss,
bevor wir Schluss machen.
Ich lese es vor:
"Wie aus der Biografie hervorgeht,
leidet Ahmad an einem Spaltwirbel,
weshalb er
an den Rollstuhl gebunden ist."
"Zusätzlich wurde ihm eine schwere
Hüftluxation diagnostiziert
und er soll nun
in der Schön Klinik in München
einer schweren Operation
unterzogen werden."
"Wir bitten Sie deshalb
um die Erteilung
einer humanitären Aufenthalts-
bewilligung für die Mutter,
damit sie während dieser Zeit
nach Deutschland kommen kann."
So.
Vielen Dank.
Erinnern Sie sich an sie?
Ja, sicher. Und ihr wollt jetzt,
dass die Mutter zu Ahmad gehen kann?
Gut, also. Name und Vorname.
Hier.
Gemacht.
Danke, tschüss.
(Mädchen) Sie sagen,
Sie erinnern sich noch gut an Ahmad.
An was denn v.a.?
Ich bin ganz gerührt.
Das ist verständlich.
Ich habe ihn ...
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Ich habe ihn oft gesehen.
In dieses Rechteck in der Mitte
kleben wir das gleiche Foto,
das im Klassenzimmer hängt.
Das mit Ahmad und uns allen.
Und drum herum
schreibt ihr eure Namen.
Aber nicht zu klein,
sonst kann die Frau es nicht lesen.
Sie ist auch nicht mehr so jung,
genau wie ich.
Gebt ihr mir mal ein paar Blätter,
damit ich sie auch
hier auflegen kann?
Klar, auch die Kinder dürfen
unterschreiben, wenn sie wollen.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Wir sammeln Unterschriften, die wir
an Angela Merkel schicken werden.
662.
Aus Roveredo.
Carena.
- 4'087 Unterschriften.
* Auf dem Handy läuft "Sofia"
von Alvaro Soler. Ahmad pfeift mit. *
# Sueño cuando era pequeño
# sin preocupación en el corazón.
# Sigo viendo aquel momento
# se desvaneció, desapareció.
* Schnelles Piepen der Parkhilfe *
* Autotür, Motor, Blinker *
Da ist er! Schau, da ist er ja!
* Lachen *
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Ich bin ganz schnell hergefahren.
Wenn ich nur für mich koche,
reicht das, oder?
Ja, das reicht. Das sind Zwiebeln.
Die musst du kleinhacken,
aber für dich allein
reicht ein Viertel von dem.
Siehst du, du kannst es schon.
- Ja.
Das sehe ich daran,
wie du den Kochlöffel hältst.
Sing das Lied, das ihr jeweils
vor dem Essen singt.
Piep, piep, piep,
wir haben alle lieb. Guten Appetit.
Sehr schön. Bravo!
(Falamaz) Du musst es auf Itali-
enisch sagen, nicht dieses Pi-pi-pi.
Nein,
so wie er es in der Schule lernt.
Wir haben eine Antwort bekommen
auf unsere Anfrage
für ein Touristenvisum
für Ahmads und Falamaz' Mutter -
Khadijah.
Ich lese euch den Brief vor:
"An die Gruppe Mütter für Ahmad."
"Wir danken Ihnen für Ihre E-Mail
an das Generalkonsulat Erbil."
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Auf Wiedersehen, Kameran.
Debora,
danke dass ihr gekommen seid.
Ich danke euch. Ciao!
Auf Wiedersehen.
Grüsse an alle in Giubiasco!
Danke.
- Grüsse an alle!
Machen wir!
Meine Freunde!
- Ja, wir werden sie grüssen!
"Es ist verständlich,
dass Ahmads Mutter
nach der jahrelangen Trennung
nach Deutschland kommen möchte,
um dem Sohn nach der Operation
zusammen mit dem Vater beizustehen."
"Gleichzeitig ist die Erteilung
eines Visums nicht möglich,
wenn eine Rückkehr der Asylsuchenden
nicht genügend
gesichert werden kann."
"Aufgrund der Tatsache,
dass sich der Mann und die Söhne
vermutlich nicht legal
in Europa aufhalten
und dass zurzeit in Deutschland ein
Asylverfahren für sie hängig ist,
können wir nicht von einer
sicheren Rückkehr ausgehen."
Ich habe Angst.
* Ahmad heult. *
"Daher kann in dieser Situation
kein dringendes Touristenvisum
erteilt werden."
Komm zu mir. Oh, ja, ja.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Bis gleich.
Ich komme gleich, um zu reden.
Es wird alles gut gehen.
Ja, wir sind da für Ahmad.
Sei ancora un po' stanco?
- Ich schaue kurz nach dem Gips.
* Wimmern *
Ist es besser auf der Seite?
Nicht besser?- Willst du
auf der anderen Seite liegen?
Willst du zur Tür gucken?
- Hmm.
Auch nicht?
- Dann schlaf.
* Wimmern, weinen *
Es wird dir bald besser gehen,
du wirst sehen.
* Ahmad spricht weinend arabisch. *
Es geht vorbei.
Ich muss die Augen schliessen
und herausfinden, wer mich berührt.
Wer berührt dich jetzt?
Ich oder dein Papa?
Du.
- Und wo?- Hier.
Richtig. Sehr gut.
Du kneifst mich.
Entschuldige. Ist es so besser?
Was fasse ich an?
- Den hier!
Sehr gut! Bravo!
* Ahmad singt. *
Wer berührt dich jetzt?
Ich oder dein Papa?
Beide.
- Bravo!
Olé! Bravo!
- Olé!
Olé!
* Jubel, Klatschen *
Mein kleiner Liebling.
Wie schön, du spürst deine Füsse!
Gib mir das Handy!
Ich wundere mich, dass er sich
nicht beklagt mit diesem Riesengips.
Ich bete zu Gott,
dass er sich rasch erholt.
Gott sei Dank hält er durch.
- Möge Gott uns helfen.
(Ariella) Sind wir da?
(Debora) Ja.
Schau mal, da steht ein Bär.
Wie hübsch.
* Autotür *
Schön ist es hier.
Und auch schön warm.
Ja, jetzt ist es heiss.
Dort drüben ist ein Fluss.
Echt schön.
Wohin gehen wir? Da lang?
(Ariella) Ja.
Schneller, Falamaz, schneller.
Dann fahr doch alleine!
(Debora)
Nein! Hast du mich erschreckt!
(Falamaz)
Geh nur, ich kenne dich nicht!
Warte!
* Kreischen, Rufen *
* Zungenschnalzen *
Eins, zwei, hopp!
- Hui!
Ich glaube, sie nehmen ihn ganz weg.
Mein Gips ist ganz hart,
man kann ihn kaum aufschneiden.
Hey! Ist gut?
Fresh air?
(Alle) Acht ... neun ...
... zehn.
- Sagen wir noch fünf?
11 ... 12 ... 13 ... 14.
Und 15.
- Super.
Aua!
- Entschuldigung.
* Er spricht arabisch. *
Gut!
- Mir ist ganz schwindlig.
Fast wie ein Fohlen,
das grade auf die Welt gekommen ist.
Damit kommst du einfacher
in die Turnschuhe.
Jetzt du. Okay.
- Ja.
Ja!
- Gut!
Meine Beine sind ganz steif,
ich kann sie kaum bewegen.
* Kameran spricht arabisch. *
Papa, das tut weh.
Halt dich an ihr fest.
- Hat er Schmerzen?
Fa male.
- Dann bleiben wir mal stehen.
Gut machst du das, super!
Das ist natürlich anstrengend,
er lag sechs Wochen nur auf ...
Wirklich?
Okay.
Warte, warte!
Muss man das noch hochmachen?
- Ja, warte.
Kannst du deutsch?- Ja, ein
bisschen, er versteht es ganz gut.
Warum muss er arabisch reden,
wenn du alles verstehst?
* Lachen *
Damit es mein Papa versteht.
Ah!
Sehr gut.
- Nicht so grosse Schritte.
Weiter können wir nicht,
sonst fällt Mustafa in den Spiegel.
Okay? Versuch mal selber zu stehen.
Gross machen, strecken.
Ja, genau. Gut!
* Seufzen *
(Debora)
Gut machst du das, sehr gut.
Lieber Ahmad,
fast vier Jahre sind vergangen,
seit ihr deine Mama,
deine Schwester Laila
und deinen Bruder Rasoul
im Irak zurückgelassen habt.
Ich frage mich, ob du
beim Einschlafen neben deinem Papa
immer noch jeden Abend
die gleiche Frage stellst:
"Wann kommt Mama endlich?"
Zu den Müttern aus Giubiasco
sind weitere Mütter hinzugekommen,
auch aus München.
Sie haben alles versucht,
um eine Antwort auf deine Frage
zu erhalten, aber es kam keine.
Doch dann, eineinhalb Jahre nachdem
ihr die Schweiz verlassen habt,
erhaltet ihr das Recht,
in Deutschland zu bleiben.
Und dann: die grosse Neuigkeit.
(Debora) Meine Lieben.
Nach all den vergeblichen Versuchen
scheint endlich etwas
in Gang zu kommen.
Khadijah wurde auf die
deutsche Botschaft im Irak bestellt.
Hoffen wird, dass es diesmal klappt
und Ahmads Mutter
bald nachkommen kann.
* Nachrichtenton *
* Khadijah spricht arabisch. *
Wann bist du dran?
Um 9.45 Uhr.
Es ist nicht weit von hier.
Hast du alle Dokumente bereit?
Ja, es liegt alles bereit.
Wirst du heute Abend beten?
Ich habe schon so viel gebetet,
dass mir der Kopf platzt.- Ah!
Seit vier Jahren
bin ich ständig am Beten,
du kannst sicher sein,
dass ich es heute auch tue.
Ich glaube, mein Bruder
kann nicht mehr so gut Italienisch.
Ah!
Ich habe den Eindruck,
er weiss nicht,
dass valigia Koffer heisst.
Valigia ist doch
ein total einfaches Wort.
Das ist die Tasche, in die man
die Kleider und alles reintut,
wenn man woanders hinzieht.
Stimmt's?
Aber weisst du,
inzwischen habe ich mich
schon ein bisschen daran gewöhnt,
ohne Mama zu sein.
Ich habe mich daran gewöhnt.
Und jetzt, wo sie kommt?
Ich weiss nicht.
Weisst du, warum ich jetzt
immer so schöne Sachen mache?
Nein, warum?
All diese Sachen
mache ich für meine Mama.
Welche Sachen denn?
- Gehen und das alles.
Das machst du für deine Mama?
- Ja.
Und für meine ganze Familie.
* Gong *
(Durchsage) Abflug Lufthansa 5730
nach Stockholm.
Alle Passagiere dieses Fluges
werden gebeten,
sich nun zum Ausgang B einzufinden.
Departure flight 543 to Stockholm,
all passengers concerned are
kindly requested to proceed to ...
* Weinen *
Mama!
* Sanfte, orientalische Saitenmusik *
Ah!
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2020